c'était une réponse apportée à l'attack
des policiers par un groupe de jeunes à
poissy une réunion avec l'ensemble des
partenaires de la ville s'est tenue ce
mardi 16 février à l'hôtel de ville
des représentants de l'état des forces
de police de l'éducation de l'emploi du
logement des associations et des acteurs
de terrain
la principale du collège jean jaurès
nous est que il était totalement
déscolarisés mais tenez vous bien
ils n'ont pas depuis leur entrée au
collège quasiment depuis la maternelle
avec une paupérisation intellectuelle
des familles
donc on le voit bien que c'est bien plus
profond que c'est le simple fait de
jeter à mortier
ces jeunes ne se dépense plus ils vivent
dans leurs quartiers populaires en
général dans leurs familles souvent des
familles nombreuses donc dans des
espaces qui sont réduits c'est sûr que
c'est pas une norme en tant que tel pour
autant est-ce excusable que d'aller
jeter des mortiers à l'endroit des
forces de police la crise sanitaire
n'arrange pas la situation cette
patrouille de police prise à partie par
des jeunes rappelle l'urgence d'agir
dans les quartiers populaires notamment
pour l'état à travers ses compétences
c'est la mise en place avec le délégué
du préfet par exemple delà des sites de
formation sur laïcité sur le fait
religieux
c'est le travail qui est fait sur la
rénovation urbaine c'est à sa tombe dead
que l'on peut faire de nombreux
dispositifs sont aussi mises en place
par la commune en collaboration avec
d'autres collectivités
c'est le cas de la prévention
spécialisée du département des yvelines
avec l'association y fait
les éducateurs sont embauchés localement
pour encadrer des jeunes de quartiers
populaires sur le quartier de
saint-exupéry on a eu bien moins de
problèmes parce que la prévention
spécialisée et est présente occupe entre
guillemets ces jeunes échangent avec ces
jeunes et de temps en temps lorsque ces
jeunes déborde et bien les les recadre
il ya un besoin effectivement de
communication pour rappeler plus que
jamais les règles et rappelait plus que
jamais les règles c'est rencontrer
rencontrer ces jeunes le maire de poissy
karl olive a d'ores et déjà prévu de
rencontrer les jeunes du quartier
beauregard d'ici la fin de la semaine